That concludes the public speakers list.
And now we will move on to welcome
the Director, margaret Wallace Brown and Roger Hamilton,
to provide the Planning and Development Budget workshop presentation.
Welcome, Director, and the floor is yours. Thank you. Good afternoon,
council members. Let me begin by introducing
the team that I have with me today. We may be relying on them for
some answers to questions, so I want to make sure I introduce them.
First of all, at my right is Roger Hamilton. He is our department CFO
and he leads the finance team, which includes Alejandro Garcia,
Maribel Torres and Donnella Gamilian. Also with us
today is our communication team and council liaison, elise Marion
and Anna Sedillo. And then the other part
of our leadership in our department is our Deputy Director,
Jennifer Austland, and our Assistant Director in Chief Transportation
Planner, David Fields. And so I may be leaning on some of
them for some of your questions. Let me go ahead and
start. So my name is Margaret Wallace Brown. I'm the director of
the Planning and Development Department. And before I present an overview
of the Planning and Development Department budget, I'd like to take a moment to
reaffirm my deep appreciation for your support of the planning
team and all the work we do. We take great pride in being
a resource for the Mayor and Council districts and our fellow departments.
We take our work very seriously when we work with you.
In 2021, we adopted a new mission statement
growing and Preserving Houston's Diverse Communities to create a
resilient city with record number of platts and
permits and an increasing portfolio of new projects.
2021 has been our most productive year and
our most innovative year. I'd like to demonstrate how we are fulfilling that mission
as I share a few highlight reels of our accomplishments.
First of all, our platting requests hit an all time high with
over more than 3000 platts in 2021. That was
a 25% increase on our previous record year,
which was 2020. We also saw a steady increase in building
permits, with 22 300 building permits planners
reviewing approximately 1200 plans per month.
On a different note, Friedmanstown was designated as the city's first heritage
district. We also added ten more landmarks, a new
historic district, and we have another one in the works. Our team is
engaging with residents in Glenburg Valley, where we conducted a window workshop
and worked on design guidelines for three historic districts.
More accomplishments include our transportation planning area,
which our Vision Zero Action plan earned a Gold
Award for implementation from the Texas Chapter of the American Planning Association.
Vision Zero is implementing all 13 priority actions,
and highlights include continuing engagement to identify
locations of concern updating the city street designs,
redesigning ten high injury network locations,
and receiving $4 million in highway safety improvement
funding from Techstot. The first more space Main
Street patio opened with Little Dipper. Followed shortly after
that with Shay McElroy, the Flying Saucer and Finn Hall.
The More space Main Street initiative was a great success
and was approved for an extension, keeping it going through 2023 in
2021, together with our partners, we completed the Austin
Hutchins, Gray, Leland and Polk Street Bikeways,
including Cullen Boulevard. Also, they were initiated in response to
the Build 50 challenge. We added the Clear Lake West Chase Trail
extensions and segments of the Spring Branch Trail. So now
we have High comfort bikeway off of East Freeway at Federal and
Maxi and these complete 40 miles of
high comfort bike network in our city.
The transportation team also engaged with the community to build safety improvements in
Briar Meadows and set a guest with council members
Thomas and Jackson. We partnered with Harris County Health Department,
received funding from MD Anderson to start the city's first
Safe Routes to School program in Acres Home.
Our Livable Places Action Committee celebrated its first anniversary,
reached consensus on recommendations from Chapter 42 technical
amendments, which you graciously approved yesterday, established a focus
group to work on conservation districts, and released a single family residential
survey that garnered over 1200 responses. We received
a grant from the AARP, which we used to organize
an accessory dwelling unit garage apartment for
many design competition to promote compact, affordable housing
design options for Houstonians. The grant funded a series of
workshops and the design contest and culminated in the publication
of a book, all of which was managed, implemented and designed
by our staff in the complete communities planning and
development led initiatives such as Neighborhood Character preservation Tool Workshops,
Lights on Houston Community Events Building Food
Security Workshop and working with CenterPoint Energy Agency's Action Program.
So these are our accomplishments over the past year, but I also want to provide
a very brief overview of our priorities, new projects and
frequently recurring quests that we're expecting to come for the coming year.
As all of you know, we're working with council districts on Redistricting,
both on the ongoing public engagement as well as the technical and data analysis
support for realignment of district boundaries. That process
will continue through September of 2022. Staff is
creating a team to provide demographic and population projections for
the city of Houston. Up until now, we've not projected population,
we've simply identified what other agencies
have calculated. So projections will be new for us
and for the city, and it will support other city departments in right
sizing their service operations. Our transportation planners
have so many projects, it's hard to keep up, but I
hope you had a chance to listen to the Mayor's State of Mobility address this
afternoon. A transcript and a video is going to be available later
today, but in addition to that, we have increased coordination with
Metro, specifically about the University Corridor and the
Intercatty Bus Rapid Transit lines. We're also receiving frequent requests
for connectivity studies in various council districts and
Houston is the largest city in the United States without a map designating
truck routes, which means that freight travel often cuts through residential neighborhoods.
So in the coming year, the citywide Freight Map project
will coordinate with council members and neighborhoods to secure some relief for
them. And when it comes to increasing Houstonian's equity,
we're still collaborating with the Kinder Institute on the Equity Indicators
project to provide transparency, accountability and to refine
operations for all city departments to increase equity
across our city. The initial analysis is nearly completed but
and the program will require ongoing management and measure to
measure success in closing the gaps.
Our ongoing work with neighborhood resiliency plans address storm
recovery, watershed boundaries and other challenges like climate adaption,
risk reduction, economic development, infrastructure modernization
and social empowerment. Currently there are three plans to be completed
by 2023, with another three to be completed afterward.
And staff is developing a replicable framework for other neighborhoods to
follow in creating their own resiliency plans. And our
minimum lot size and minimum building line programs, which are so popular
for neighborhoods, are reaching their 20 year threshold,
which means that we're creating significant increase in we're getting
requests for significant increase in renewals on top of the average projected
new applications. And finally,
historic preservation team we've created.
Two new historic districts have been petitioned and we
are working with the Economic Development Office for review and administration
of the historic Site tax exemption program, which is growing in popularity.
We expect conservation districts to presented to city Council within the next
few months. A conservation district for Independence Heights will
probably follow shortly thereafter. We see conservation districts as
providing neighborhoods another tool for protecting their character. So I'm
excited about all the partnerships we've forged and look forward to working with
you on another collaborative year. Let's dig into the numbers
now. The Planning and Development Department operates out of four separate
funds. It's important to note, and I will discuss this in detail later,
that while expenditures are specific to a fund's function,
our team members operate in a silo free environment.
In the Planning Department, it's talent, not titles,
that informs the work of a team member does. And very few of our team
members conduct one job within one fund. Most handle
projects in multiple funds and we assign the costs accordingly.
I'm telling you this because we stress importance
of knowledge beyond their cubicle. It's my belief that
this provides better professional training to our team and makes for a better city
employee. The result is that we utilize a series of inner fund chargebacks
and reimbursements that will seem confusing at first, but I'll explain
them in detail as we get to them. So the first
fund is the city's general fund. The FY 23
budget is $3,000,925 $3,925,384
with 23.1 full time equivalents.
The fund supports our community engagement and transportation planning efforts as
well as our management and customer support services. The second
fund, the Department's Special Revenue Fund, supports the work of the majority
of our team members. This fund receives fees
from and pays for services related to land development
activities within the 671 sq. Mi of the
City of Houston, as well as the 1600 additional square miles
in the city's extraterritorial jurisdiction. The team
at the permitting center are also on this fund. The third
fund, the city's central services revolving fund also known as
the Enterprise GIS or just simply Egis fund,
supports the work of our GIS team located both at 611
Walker and at the Houston Emergency center as a central service
revolving fund operation. All expenditures in this
area are charged back to the department that consume our services under their
restricted accounts. The FY 23 budget
is $1,736,847
with 11.5 full time employees.
And finally, the Historic Preservation Fund, which is a small fund used
for nonpersonal special preservation activities that was
created several years ago with the proceeds of the sale of some city owned historic
fire stations. I'd like to take the time to discuss the
programming and the core functions we handle in the Planning Department.
Our department consists of seven divisions community and Regional Planning,
transportation Planning, GIS Services,
historic Preservation, Development Services,
Management Services and the Director's Office for
Community and Regional Planning. This group is led by Deputy Director Jennifer Austland
and directly supports community planning with programs such as Complete
Communities minimum Lot Size Building Line prohibited yard parking.
They are also responsible for broader regional planning, such as annexations
and changes to boundaries, including the city's extraterritorial jurisdiction.
This group is the group currently working with you on Council Redistricting.
The next division is Transportation planning. Led by David Fields, the city's
Chief Transportation Planner, the division leads the city's
systems level strategic Mobility planning. This function
includes management of the city's Complete Streets and Transportation Plan,
Vision Zero, the Major Thoroughfare and Freeway plan, the Houston
Bike Plan, rail related planning, local area studies
and external transportation funding and grant efforts.
This is the team that's facilitating the discussions about the North Houston Highway
Improvement Project, and some of our newest initiatives include connectivity
studies for Houston neighborhoods the GIS
Services Division. Led by Assistant Director Larry Nerth,
this division manages and maintains much of the city's GIS information,
provides and coordinates regional emergency providers with mapping and
analysis for effective emergency services. As I often
say, if you need an ambulance and it can find you, that's because our
GIS group told it how to get there. This is also the group that
provides the map indicating services, facilities and developments within your
district. The next division is historic preservation.
Roman McAllen is the city's Historic Preservation Officer and he leads
this group. They facilitate the process of identifying and maintaining the city's
historic resources through engagement with neighborhoods and
property owners. This group manages certificates of appropriateness
applications pertaining to Chapter 33 of the Code of Ordinances,
as well as coordinating state and federal review of historic resources
development services. Deputy Director Jennifer Austin
leads this division also which oversees many development related activities
including subdivision and development, platting and site plan review at the
Houston Permitting Center. The last two
are management Services and support the division responsible for
operational support of the department, including budgeting, purchasing commission
support, customer service and public information and open records.
And then finally, the Director's Office, which handles all internal communications
such as employee onboarding and training, as well as communications with
the Mayor's office in your council, district offices and the public.
Moving on to Revenues by Funds this
slide is an overview of the proposed FY 23 revenue by fund in comparison
to the department's estimated FY 22 revenue.
Overall, we are proposing a revenue increase of 139,000
across all funds focusing on the General Fund line.
Revenue into the general fund is primarily from a chargeback from the department's
special revenue fund. As I mentioned earlier, team members who
are primarily paid out of the General Fund but spend some portion of
their time working on development related activities that support the
Special Revenue Fund. Their activities are reimbursed to
the General Fund. The General Fund revenue is projected to increase by
77,000 or 5.5% from the
FY 22 estimate. Moving on to the special revenue
fund. This is Planning and Development special revenue fund dedicated to
the department's development related services.
These are services as a regulator to ensure orderly development
in the city and our extraterritorial jurisdiction. They include
functions such as the review of Platts, residential site plans and development
plats, including work with the Planning Commission as well as our site plan
review at the Houston Permitting Center. The Special Revenue Fund is funded with
revenue from fees associated with these reviews and dedicates that revenue for
services in support of development activity. A portion of
that revenue is received by the Special Revenue Fund is due to
team members who are primarily paid out of Special Revenue Fund but spend
some portion of their time working on community engagement, transportation, planning efforts
and management customer support activities that are technically General
Fund. We expect a slight decrease in the revenue of
43,000 or 4%
4% of this fund compared to FY 22
for fluctuations in revenue from various other sources. The next
line shows Central Services revolving fund, also known as the Enterprise
GIS. The fund provides critical mapping services
to the city, including creation and maintenance of the city's underlying
mapping data. The fund receives revenue from departments across
the city to pay for GIS related services. The revenue to this fund
is based on actual expenditures and as a result the
revenue can go up or down depending on vacancies in the fund or other cost
saving measures. This fund is expected to see a revenue increase of 107,000
or 6.6% and the final fund is the Historic
Preservation Fund. It was created by ordinance and is funded
through the proceeds from the sale of historic fire stations. The purpose
of this fund is to promote preservation and enhancement of the city's historic resources.
The revenue to It is simply interest on the Fund balance and we're anticipating
a 17% decrease in revenues this year.
Overall, department revenues increase 139,000
for all funds.
Shifting to Expenditures this slide is an overview of the FY
2023 budgeted budget in
comparison to the FY 22 projected current budget.
Overall, we're proposing an expenditure decrease of approximately 1,546,000
across all funds. Is that correct? The slide
provides a quick overview of expenditures.
General Fund we're proposing an increase of 14,000, or 0.4%.
The increase is largely due to hope.
To the Hope increase, Special Revenue Fund is proposed to
have a decrease of 1,629,000
or 12.1% resulting in a decrease
from Indirect Cost and Consulting Services and Central
Services Revolving Fund proposing an increase of 69,000 or 4.1%
resulting from Hope and increases in interfund charges. Finally,
the Historic Preservation Fund has no change.
This is the General Fund breakdown of expenditures.
Personnel versus non personnel approximately 3.9
million in expenditures which includes 77% for personnel
costs and 23% for non personnel cost in
the non personal expenditures. The 887,000
non personnel expenditure cost for the General Fund is broken
down. The largest category is the restricted accounts.
These expenses are not controlled by the Department and make up 97% of
the non personnel cost of this fund and then services
and supplies about 33,000 or 3% of the non
personnel expenditures.
Next slide. This slide illustrates the projected budget expenditures
for the Special Revenue Fund. The Fund's approximate 11
million in expenditures includes 57% for personnel
costs and 43% for non personnel cost
in FY 23. The nonpersonal cost for the Department's Special Revenue Fund
is as follows indirect cost recovery is 8%
or 411,000. This cost is for indirect
services provided by Central services departments and is not controlled by the Department.
Interfund Services 29% is the chargeback
that's paid to General Fund for development related activities that I mentioned earlier.
Plat Tracker and Historic Tracker web Application Redesign
I want to point out that this is a major expense this fund will see
for the next several years. Plat Tracker, which is the primary portal through
which all development related applications are submitted, is close to ten years
old and is built on 13 year old technology. We've been
working closely with It and Special Purchase and Strategic Purchasing
for two years to develop an RFP for the reconstruction of
this portal later this summer in June, you'll see
a contract on your agenda to actually begin rebuilding
this application. The restricted
accounts is 17% of the non personnel cost and is not controlled by the Department
and supplies and services is a combined 8% for
supplies and services, computer supplies and so forth. Next slide
the breakdown of the FY 23 expenditures for Central Services revolving
fund. The fund's approximately 1.7 million
in expenditures includes 86% for personnel cost and
14% for non personnel costs in
FY 23. The non personnel costs for the fund are broken down.
49% includes various services and charges related
to the fund, including technology, services and software.
And then 40% of the non personnel cost in this fund is not controlled by
the Department. Those are restricted accounts. And finally,
11% is for computer supplies, offices,
et cetera. Next slide. The breakdown
of the proposed FY 23 expenditures for the Historic Preservation Fund
include approximately 150,000 in
expenditures and is entirely for non personnel cost.
There are no FTEs paid for out of this fund.
The nonpersonal cost includes miscellaneous
support services, which include funding for translation services for
the Historic Commission meetings and the completion of the design guidelines
for the historic areas in Houston.
This slide shows our FY 23 projected fund balance
I'm sorry projected General Fund budget expenditures
net change to our FY 2022 projected current
budget. The FY 23 projected current budget is
3.9 million. There's a one time operating budget adjustment for
the position that was funded in FY 22 for the Office of Resilience and
Sustainability that our Ara will now fund contractual
or mandated adjustments of 115,000 that
consist of the municipal pension reduction and an increase in the restricted
accounts and hope pay increases resulting in an operating program increase
of 15,000. This brings our FY 2023
projected budget to 3.9 million or an increase of 0.4%.
Any questions? Thank you for your presentation,
council Member Alcorn. Thank you Chair.
And thank you, Director, for all the great work you do at the Planning Department.
Thanks for talking about Plat tracker. I was going to ask about the increase
in management. I guess it's under the
management consulting services. That's the big thing. And I know we we budgeted
last year $2.6 million in that line item and spent $300,000.
Can you just talk to me about that? Was it just delayed or
were we expecting to spend that last year or what have you? We did expect
to spend it last year, so about two years ago we started working with it
on looking at how can we fix what we have because it is old,
so let's just fix it. And it's answer was
we really can't fix it. We need to really start from scratch. And so we
expected it to be a shorter time frame in order to do the RFP and
to get the money spent for rebuilding it. It actually took longer
because we were more detailed. We went through a
very robust conversation with the bidders
on this and have developed an incredibly secure
program that it supports that we're going to move forward with.
The 300,000 that was spent last year was actually what
led us to such a good resolution in that we had a contract
with Gartner and Company to help us actually draft the RFP
got it. And since they didn't bid on it and so that's like a
lesser expense, the $1.9 million in the 2.6, do we expect
there to be more in coming years towards this you said this will be a
major expense for it'll be an expense for at least seven years.
It is a one year implementation project with six years of
full, virtually 24 hours support for
our customers and for our staff. So we're very pleased with this process.
Okay. And I've got some other questions about the primarily
around the planning and development special revenue fund. You mentioned
that some of the general fund employees support the
efforts of that and vice versa. Some of the
employees that are paid for through the Planning and Development Special Revenue
Fund also do general fund functions and vice
versa. Okay. I guess my question is,
was that the intent of putting the I mean, was it was it all
was it supposed to be the Planning and Development Special Revenue Fund over at permitting
was supposed to just support those efforts, or was it always meant to
be fluid? Well, so when the fund
was created so the fees
are for land development activities that the City
of Houston does, whether it's Platting or permitting over at the permitting
center. So the fund supports
those activities, but it also supports some development related
activities, such as a few positions that do minimum
lot size designations, because those are development related.
It supports some of our transportation planning. And as we have
worked with this fund for three years, what we've been able to determine
is that some team members specialties really afford them.
They have the best skills and the best ability to do a
type of service such as outreach. Some of that outreach will
be development related, some of it won't be. And so that's
why we charge back and reimburse
the funds, is because if, say, for instance, one of our
planners is terrific at outreach,
she will work with the development side work as
well as the non development side. And we need to make sure we're clear on
which fund pays her. Okay, I have some more if you put me back in.
Did I answer your question? Yes. Okay, let's be mindful. We're about
45 minutes behind schedule.
Council Member Cayman,
I'm happy to defer to Council Member Alcorn if she wants to wrap up.
All right, Director, first off,
I know you all are dealing with a lot right now. And then on top
of that, to throw in redistricting.
I don't know how you all are doing it all, but thank you. And again.
David Fields. So many others. I'm not
going to start naming people because I'll get in trouble. But whether it's in
District C, the Historic districts, the Heritage District,
Vision Zero's Implementation, I'm so excited to hear about the new
freight mapping. I think that's going to be a very big deal,
especially in District C. On top of
all of that, any meeting my constituents have asked for, you and your staff
have been to. So thank you for being available to
our residents for all of their questions. In times of great
concern and need. One of the concerns I just want to continue to
raise and elevate in any way that I can. I know as a city
we have to build denser, we have to have affordable
housing, we have to make it convenient for people in parts
of the district. I continue to be concerned about, for example,
in Shady Acres, in Lazy Brook Timbergrove, but especially Shady Acres
that as we're building hyper densely,
we still don't have the infrastructure to mitigate and
manage all of the building that's going on. So I know that's
not a question. I just, on behalf of residents, have to continue to
emphasize the need to as we build dense
that we're building responsibly. And I know you take that charge very seriously
as it relates to the department itself.
May I respond to that for a moment? We do take it very seriously and
I think that our Livable Places Action Committee is working very
hard and very intently on fixing some of that. But I
also want to say that our partnership with the Houston Public Works
Department is better than it has ever been. And so the work that we're
doing with development and developers and property owners in
the city is really being amplified by the work that
they're doing in the general I'm sorry, in the Chief
Engineer's office. And the partnership is really putting forth ideas
for a better Houston and I couldn't agree more.
So, again, I appreciate that and really look forward to the additional measures
and improvements as they come along really quickly.
Future needs of the department. Again, tight budget,
what do we need to be on the lookout for or be aware of that's
not being satisfied by this current budget this year.
So we anticipate future needs of the department include, besides special
revenue fund activities, some general fund activities that could be
that conservation District working with the Conservation District
is a new program we're creating this year. We also would like to do
more resiliency plans for neighborhoods that would take more
team members. And we believe that the tools we have
in place, such as minimum lot size and minimum building line, are very
good for neighborhoods and they very much want to opt into them.
Having the number of people who can support that has been difficult recently.
Council Member Alcorn, as you mentioned, Director, you have
really increased the number of plans you're reviewing over at the permitting center.
So I noticed in your budget, it looks like going to
get two more FTEs in development design review,
one more in development services, three more in development support
services. Do you think that that's sufficient to I noticed in today's
dashboard you've got about 1900 plans in planning
at about 27 days. I know you're working towards a goal of 13 days
for commercial, ten days for residential. So do you think you
need more people there to tackle the great number of increase in
plans. I think that right now we are seeing
such an immense increase in the plans that, yes,
right now I could use double the team, but I
have to be really cautious because the Special Revenue Fund is a self fulfilling
fund. It is not like right. Not like the general fund. It comes
from the fees that we collect and we
have this huge expense for Plat tracker. And so as that
works its way out to you for approval over the next month,
once I get that number nailed down, I'll be able to analyze
where I can go and how I can increase funding at a much more safe
way. So that's when I'll take that step. Does your department offer
customer paid expediting? Yes, we do expedite.
Can you describe that to me a little bit?
So if a customer asks
for expedited review and pays it by
09:00 a.m. That morning, I believe
we have the plan out for them within 24
hours of the 24 hours from the time they pay the fee, I believe.
Does the charge depend on the complexity of the project or
is it a flat? Council Member, can I get back to you? Sure, absolutely.
Thank you very much.
Thank you, Director and Mr. Hamilton for your presentation.
You all are now dismissed. Thank you. We will now begin
the public comment period. We will start with our virtual speakers.
Please press star six to unmute when you hear your name. The first speaker
is Saba Blandy. Hey,
good afternoon. I just had two quick questions for this department.
I appreciate the expansion to the High Comfort Bicycle Network,
and I was curious what the overall timeline of expansion was.
And I was also curious, as somebody who lives near a
bus stop, if there's a plan to make sidewalks near public transit
Ada accessible, because the ones near ours are not.
So we'll need to get back
to you on question one. So if you want to send that to District E
at houstontx Gov, we'll get you a specific response on that.
As it pertains to question two? As it
pertains to question two, yes, I believe there is
a strategy in place to provide sidewalks and Ada
accessibility for Metro bus stops in those
areas. And there are some plans that are in the works
that our offices are collaborating with Metro. I know
in District J we did a recent initiative with Metro
regarding our bus stops, and they were very intentional on finding
bus stops with proper sidewalks and Ada accessibility.
So that is on our radar.
That is a priority for us to continue to look at and be able to
be mindful to try to get as many bus stops up
to date with those type of amenities as possible around the city.
So if you see one in your area, wherever you are in your district,
try to advocate for that. Reach out to your district. Council Member
and stay engaged with us. Absolutely. Thank you.
Council Member David Robinson. Thank you, Chair, and Ms. Blanding,
thank you again for being here so alertly
with our panels. And in this case, I think I'd
like to call your attention to the city's website for
the TTI committee briefings. Recently, there has been
a presentation, yes, by planning, but also in
conjunction with the Mayor's Office for persons with disabilities. Director Gabe
Costarez has addressed some of those things. And I
think that the video recording of that
you would find interesting and perhaps helpful. And if you need a reference to
where within the presentation that content occurred,
my office can help you. If you reach out to the AtLarge two office for
that. So I appreciate the good questions and your ongoing attendance.
Thank you so much.
Amanda psy.
Please press star six to unmute.
Amanda Sigh, please press star six to unmute.
Hello.
I'm not prepared right now, so I'll go ahead and yield my time.
Mr. Jason oliver.
Hello, and thank you to the Planning Department for
the Redistricting website is really valuable. It has
a lot of resources. It's been helpful for me trying to understand
this and the language accessibility there. I'm wondering
if there's a centralized online place where the CIP kind
of information is being shared during these meetings are all accessible.
That's a whole separate budget adoption. That's much
hard to navigate. And I feel like it's kind of falling under the radar
with all that's happening with Redistricting.
And then second, as the city transitions to outcomes based
budgeting, the Finance Department told us that planning would be the group
to facilitate public engagement around it. So what
existing plans are in action and how can we enhance the budget
process to encourage engagement? For example, holding workshops before
the proposed budget is released and extending the timeline so that there's more opportunity
and it's not kind of rushed in the way that it is now.
Council Member David Robinson. Yes. Mr. Oliver, thanks again for your good
question. I think with regard to the activities of the CIP
programs, we have the last meeting tonight. As I'm sure you're
aware, the District B office and
our District B meeting is this evening.
But I think your question is a good one to get all of those activities
consolidated in a place on the web. So I'm interested in
following up with you. Of course, that relates to activities, as you said,
central to the Finance Department as well as to public works.
So to have some kind of centralized location
for that CIP information, let's see what we can do to
help you on that one. Okay. And additionally jason.
Thank you. We are working to schedule our
CIP special call BFA meeting in June.
So after we go through the budget presentations as a
committee, we will take up the CIP and present that to the public
so you can stay engaged with the process through that way as well. So we'll
put the information out on that shortly.
Thank you. That completes our public
speakers.